lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es explorar la idea de diferencia
habilidad en un punto déjame notarlo y
esta palabra es una forma elegante de
decir es si la derivada de una función
está definida en un cierto punto así que
recordemos cuál es la definición de
derivada y bueno hay muchas formas de
escribirla recuerdas en este vídeo vamos
a utilizar la definición que dice la
derivada de una función f
en un punto sep efe prima de se observa
que estoy usando la anotación de
lagrange porque estoy escribiendo f
prima ok
efe prima de c es igual al límite cuando
x tiende a c df tx - fcc entre x menos c
y seguramente la primera vez que ves
esta fórmula te suele parecer un poco
extraña pero simplemente es calcular una
pendiente observa aquí tenemos el cambio
en los valores de la función o lo puedes
pensar como el cambio en james porque
recuerda que es igual a fx entre el
cambio en x y lo que estamos intentando
es calcular cuánto vale está pendiente
cuando x se acerca más y más y más hace
o dicho de otra manera estamos
intentando calcular esta pendiente
cuando el cambio en x se acerca más y
más y más a 0 y ya hemos hablado de esto
en otros vídeos así que en este vídeo
voy a hacer algunas afirmaciones
importantes de nuevo no voy a probar
rigurosamente cada una de las
afirmaciones ya que existe otro vídeo en
el cual voy a hablar con más detalle de
la prueba de cada una de ellas pero por
ahora vamos a verlas usando un poco de
intuición la primera afirmación que
quiero ver es la siguiente
sí efe
diferenciable
x igual hace entonces
efe es continua en x igual hace entonces
f es continua en x igual a cero es decir
sí efe es diferenciable entonces podemos
encontrar este límite de acuerdo y
entonces nuestra función es continuar en
ese valor x igual a cero ojo no es
necesariamente afirmativo el caso
contrario no es forzoso que si una
función es continua entonces sea
diferenciable en ese punto pero sí
podemos afirmar lo siguiente y esta es
otra forma de escribir lo mismo que
acabo de decir si f
no es continúan sé si f no es continua
en x igual hace entonces
efe no será diferenciable en x igual a 0
y es más déjame darte algunos ejemplos
de funciones no continuas y con ellas
pensemos cuando podemos encontrar este
límite así que la primera gráfica es
aquí donde tenemos una discontinuidad
aquí nuestra función está definida en x
igualase pero puedes ver que cuando x
toma valores más grandes que sea la
gráfica se desplaza hacia abajo así que
qué es lo que pasa cuando intentamos
tomar este límite bueno recuerda lo
único que se hace mención arriba es a la
pendiente cuando x toma un valor
arbitrario
así que tomemos lo por aquí aquí tenemos
el punto x coma efe de x por acá tenemos
el punto c
fcc y si tú buscas el límite por la
izquierda de este límite esencialmente
lo que quieres encontrar es está
pendiente de aquí y es más intentemos
acercarnos más y buscar está pendiente
observa si nos acercamos más buscando
está pendiente y nos acercamos más
búsqueda está pendiente en todos los
casos la pendiente será igual a cero así
que una forma de pensarlo es que la
derivada es decir el límite cuando nos
aproximamos por la izquierda parece
se aproxima a cero ahora qué pasa si
tomamos algunas equis a la derecha y
ahora por acá tenemos el punto x
efe de x y entonces observan cuando nos
tomamos la pendiente entre estos dos
puntos es decir f de x
efe [ __ ] esto sería la pendiente de esta
recta y si aquí se acerca un poco más
tenemos la pendiente de esta otra recta
y si nos acercamos más tenemos la
pendiente de esta otra recta y entonces
observa entre más y más y más nos
acerquemos a ser nuestra pendiente de
hecho tiende a menos infinito pero lo
más importante es que tienden a valores
completamente distintos por la derecha y
por la izquierda esta expresión se está
aproximando a valores distintos por la
derecha y por la izquierda y por lo
tanto en este caso este límite no existe
eso quiere decir que la función es no
diferenciables una vez más no estamos
haciendo la prueba rigurosa aquí sólo
estamos trabajando con la intuición de
una función que
al menos en este caso es claramente no
continua y por lo tanto resulta ser no
diferenciables bien traigamos otro caso
por aquí
ahora tenemos lo que se conoce como una
discontinuidad removible o un punto de
discontinuidad así que una vez más vamos
a aproximarnos por la izquierda si este
es x entonces este es el punto x
fx y lo que es interesante es la
expresión que tenemos de la pendiente
entre los puntos x ftx y c
fcc es decir en este punto no ese punto
porque recuerda tenemos una
discontinuidad removible así que esta
expresión está calculando la pendiente
de esta recta y si x se acerca un poco
más a c ahora tenemos la pendiente de
esta recta y si nos acercamos un poco
más ahora tenemos la pendiente de esta
recta así que si nos aproximamos por la
izquierda es decir si extiende hace por
la izquierda tenemos el caso en el que
la pendiente de esta recta se aproxima a
menos infinito
y ahora si nos aproximamos por la
derecha es decir por valores mayores
hacen bueno entonces tengo la pendiente
entre estos dos puntos
ahora tenemos una pendiente positiva
pero cada vez se hace más positiva de
cualquier manera esto no se está
aproximando a un valor finito por un
lado tendremos a más infinito y por el
otro lado a menos infinito y por lo
tanto el límite de esta expresión no
existe una vez más no estoy dando una
prueba rigurosa pero estoy intentando
construir una función que sea
discontinua y en donde podamos encontrar
este límite y justo aquí está el
interesante será posible que está la
situación en donde f no está definida en
sem y por lo tanto no es continua bueno
tampoco si f no está definida en sem
entonces esta parte fcc aquí en el
límite no tendrá sentido y en definitiva
no sería diferenciable bueno ahora vamos
a pensar en lo siguiente ya te di
ejemplos donde la función no es continua
y por lo tanto no fue diferenciable
también hicimos otra declaración
recuerdas nos preguntábamos si existía
una función efe que fuera continua y que
no fuera diferenciable y bueno hay
muchas funciones podemos dar un número
infinito de funciones que son continuas
pero no diferenciables así que por
ejemplo aquí tenemos la función valor
absoluto pero por supuesto no
forzosamente tiene que ser esta función
en este caso tenemos la función que
igual al valor absoluto de x menos ser y
porque esta función no es diferenciable
en x igual hace bueno piensa un poco en
esa expresión piensa un poco en lo que
está pasando de nuevo vamos a intentar
calcular las pendientes entre el punto x
coma ftx y el punto que hace como fcc
así que si x está por aquí tenemos aquí
al punto x coma fx y entonces estamos
aproximando nos hace por la izquierda y
observa tenemos esta pendiente si nos
acercamos un poco más tenemos la misma
pendiente y aún más tenemos la misma
pendiente que en este caso es una
pendiente negativa
así que si x
por la izquierda este límite tomará un
valor negativo pero si aquí se
aproximase por la derecha este límite
observa va a ser igual a 1 va a ser la
pendiente de esta recta que conecta a
todos estos puntos y su pendiente es 1
así que el límite por la derecha es 1 el
límite por la izquierda es un valor
negativo de hechos menos 1 entonces se
está aproximando a dos valores distintos
mientras que se acercasen ya sea por la
derecha o por la izquierda y entonces
podemos concluir que este límite no
existe por la derecha nos estamos
aproximando al valor de uno por la
izquierda al valor de menos uno y por lo
tanto esta función no es diferenciable
déjame poner que no
e intuitivamente si pensamos en la
pendiente de la recta tangente observe
que aquí podemos dibujar una infinidad
de rectas tan clientes podemos decir que
tal vez esta sea la recta tangente o tal
vez esta sea la recta tangente esta
también pasa por el punto se coma cero y
podemos seguir haciendo esto porque no
es esta la recta tangente y seguir y
seguir y seguir así que quiero que te
quedes con la intuición detrás de esta
declaración y aunque no la probé aquí
pero lo haré en un vídeo futuro es
importante que la tengas presente si f
es diferenciable en sem entonces f es
continua en x igual a cero que también
se puede decir de la siguiente manera si
f no es continua n que es igual a cm
entonces
efe no va a ser diferenciable en x igual
a c y espero que estos ejemplos te hayan
servido para obtener esa intuición y
claro también está el caso en el que
tenemos una función continua pero ojo no
forzosamente debe de ser diferenciable y
aquí está el contraejemplo la función
valdrá
de equis donde tenemos una función
continúan sem pero esta función no fue
diferenciable en x igual a cero eso es
todo por este vídeo nos vemos pronto